Daniel Mercier coin bonsoir bonsoir
Monsieur Filion alors comment vous
expliquer vous les déboires de l'e-mail
cette nouvelle annonce de fermeture mais
elle s'explique comme vous l'avez
souligné par une situation
conjoncturelle difficile dans
l'industrie portine pas juste aller chez
du Québec à l'échelle nord-américaine
mais elle s'explique aussi et ça c'est
pas nouveau j'allais dire l'industrie
porcine
conjoncturellement à des hauts et des
bas au moment de la porcée en Chine en
2019-2020 personne se plaignait bien au
contraire il fallait approvisionner la
Chine il y avait des prix records et
c'est à ce moment-là colimel poursuivit
sa croissance et vraiment une croissance
très active
et qui a fait que l'email a acheté à peu
près tout ce qui bougeait comme abattoir
au Québec et ils ont acheté à ce
moment-là au haut du marché une
entreprise le groupe Ménard et
évidemment quand on achète au haut du
marché on paye un prix en conséquence
donc problème de décision de gouvernance
de l'e-mail pour vous de mon point de
vue oui il y a eu le problème de
gouvernance de l'immel volonté de
croissance trop rapide trop ambitieuse
et il faut noter aussi que les
difficultés de l'e-mail ça cause aussi
énormément de difficultés au groupe
solio anciennement la Coopérative
fédérée qui est la grande coopérative
d'approvisionnement à la ferme au Québec
donc oui un déficit important de
gouvernance qui a amené cette situation
vraiment déplorable je le dis le
portrait de l'industrie beaucoup changé
depuis trois ans avec la pandémie cette
grève de 4 mois dont on a beaucoup parlé
à l'usine Vallée Jonction en 2021 la
guerre en Ukraine également qui fait
exploser les coûts dans le secteur
alimentaire et de l'approvisionnement
comment vole l'industrie portée
dans l'ensemble fait face à un vent de
face c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire et
la hausse des coûts et aussi bon ça
amène des fluctuations et de l'offre et
de la demande et donc là on est vraiment
dans un creux de vague il faut dire
aussi que pour l'industrie porcine et la
filière d'abattage au Québec et ailleurs
il y a aussi le problème de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre qui aggrave la situation
et pèse sur la rentabilité des abattoirs
est-ce qu'on mise trop sur les
exportations au Québec quand on regarde
nos exportations
c'est massif quand même les exportations
et beaucoup vers l'Asie est-ce qu'il y a
une erreur ici
je pourrais pas vous dire le choix des
marchés sa fluctue dans le temps il y a
eu un choix qui a été fait sur la Chine
qui ont constaté parce que la Chine
souhaite produire une bonne partie de
son alimentation mais les marchés les
uns les autres sont en fluctuation les
uns rapport aux autres par contre sur la
question de l'importance de
l'exportation la filière porcine
québécoise de tout temps depuis le début
des années 70 et une filière
exportatrice et a compté sur le marché à
l'exportation pour sa croissance sans
l'exportation faudrait réduire la taille
de la filière portée du québecoise de
plus de la moitié voire des deux tiers
donc c'est un choix qui a été fait
historiquement mais on peut pas
reprocher une filière d'être
exportatrice et amenée de la valeur
ajoutée au Québec
pas nécessairement parce que quand le
bombardier avait des difficultés on
disait pas faudrait que Bombardier
produit juste pour le Québec ça a pas de
sens mais je dirais que non pas
nécessairement mais il faut avoir une
filière qui est compétitive et je dirais
des acteurs de la filière qui
travaillent ensemble ce qu'on n'a pas vu
au cours des deux dernières années
parlons spécifiquement des producteurs
beaucoup sont en grande difficulté
financière évoquent la possibilité de
faire faillite les prix de vente qui ne
couvrent pas les coûts de production et
l'UPR nous disait cette semaine que 11%
des fermes québécoises sont jamais être
la clé sous la porte au cours des 12
prochains mois quel genre d'aide ces
producteurs ont-ils besoin
le point après plusieurs années de
bateau d'intérêt il y a certains que
il s'est créé une habitude et une
habitude d'investissement compte tenu de
bateau d'intérêt alors c'est pas
vraiment une surprise qu'à partir du
moment où les taux d'intérêt augmentent
plusieurs entreprises pas juste dans le
secteur agricole puisse se retrouver en
difficulté s'ils ont pas gardé la marge
de manœuvre nécessaire alors à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
solution potentielle c'est sur le
remboursement de la dette qui peut y
avoir des solutions mais pour les
producteurs de port du Québec je dirais
que le phénomène est pire parce que
depuis des dizaines d'années il y avait
une entente tacite que les producteurs
de port du Québec vendaient
systématiquement toujours par au Québec
pour créer de la valeur ajoutée et que
les abattoirs les acheter or on l'e-mail
est rendu tellement importante que
holymel décide de réduire son volume
d'abattage par conséquent les
producteurs n'ont pas d'autres solutions
et un élément qui est important aussi
c'est que holymel a forcé les
producteurs à accepter une baisse de
prix de 40 dollars du 100 kg pendant un
temps ce que les producteurs à un moment
donné on dit c'est assez mais il faut
noter que ce sont les contribuables qui
payent pour ça parce que quand les prix
ne couvrent pas les coûts de production
les producteurs bénéficient de
l'assurance stabilisation des revenus et
donc toutes les pertes mais pas toutes
les pertes mais les deux tiers sont
payées par le gouvernement et on peut
ajouter que Investissement Québec et
investi dans webmail et donc les
contribuables sont aussi à risque dans
cette situation alors il y aura une
annonce mardi sur le renouvellement du
plan de mise en marché entre les
acheteurs les transformateurs et
producteurs de port on en parlera la
semaine prochaine Daniel Mercier Gouin
merci d'avoir été avec nous ça m'a fait
plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]